[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Slurring] Cheers.
-[Slurring] To the good times!
-Yeah! That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let me tell you...
that you...are my best friend.
-No. No, no, no. You're my --
You're my best friend.
-No! You are!
-No, you -- you are!
-Oh, my God! You are!
[ Both laugh ]
Not only are you by best friend,
you're by best-looking friend.
'Cause you look like,
um, Jon Hamm.
That's who you look like.
Yep, you do.
-I do? I do?
-Yeah, you look like Jon Hamm
if someone microwaved his head
for, like, 20 seconds.
[ Cackles ]
-Well, you -- you have
a very distinct look, too.
You know what? You look --
You look like --
You look like the love child of
Peter Pan and Billie Jean King.
Did anybody --
Did anyone ever tell you that?
-Well, you look like
if the Bonus Jonas
survived an acid attack.
[ Laughter ]
-You know, you look like
something that George Lucas
created out of latex.
[ Laughter ]
-[Gurgling] Well, you...
[ Stifled laugh ]
You...
You know,
the more I think about it,
you're not that attractive!
-Hm?
-'Cause you have
the physique of a burrito
that's about to burst open.
-Hm.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Stifled laugh ]
-You're so ugly,
when you were born,
instead of, "Push,"
the doctor said, "Suck."
I don't know. Why would --
[ Laughter ]
Why?
-Oh, yeah!
Well, let me say something
to you, my dear, dear friend.
-Oh, I'm ready for it.
-You are so ugly,
your proctologist once said,
"My God!
This ass [bleep] has teeth!"
-[ Laughs ]
That is just absol--
-Hm! Oh, peanuts.
Speaking of nuts,
did yours ever drop?
-Hey, now, look.
You know, I know --
I know who you look like.
-[ Speaking high-pitched
gibberish ]
[ Laughter ]
-You look like -- You look like
if Bilbo Baggins
got really into whippets.
[ Laughter and applause ]
By the w-- By the way,
you are so old...
shouldn't you be building
a canoe in a Cialis commercial?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hm!
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey.
Do you remember --
Do you remember when I --
that time I visited you
in the hospital?
And it was the only time
I ever felt bad for a catheter.
[ Laughter ]
In all seriousness, man,
I really do love you!
-No, I love you, too!
I really...
-I love you! I love you!
-I love you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pah!
♪♪